Привет. В прошлом уроке мы говорили про идею пайплайна, а сейчас разбираемся с фундаментом этого пайплайна, как устроены сами модели. Зачем дизайнеру это понимать? Без знания архитектуры выбор инструмента сводится к угадыванию. Попробовал одну модель — не сработало. Попробовал другую — получилось. Через год вышла новая — и снова приходится пробовать. Когда вы понимаете архитектуру, вы заранее знаете, чего от модели ожидать. Сильные и слабые их стороны определяются не маркетингом, не свежестью этой модели, а тем, как она устроена.
внутри. Это позволяет сразу класть нужную задачу в нужную модель и не тратить время на промежуточные эксперименты. И самое главное — это знание корневое. Завтра там выйдет новая модель бананы, послезавтра новая версия Mid Journey. Имена сменятся, архитектуры останутся теми же. Поэтому дерево решений работает на новых моделях ровно так же, как и на текущих. Разберем две главные архитектуры, которые сегодня покрывают почти весь рынок генерации изображений. Это диффузионные и гибридные авторегрессивные.
Диффузионные модели — это базовая архитектура для большинства моделей, с которыми вы сталкивались. И максимально просто, как она работает.
Изначально у нас просто стопроцентный шум, затем она отрисовывает формы, потом образуется четкая структура и уже в самом конце финальное изображение.
То есть, когда ты даешь какой-то промп, например, нарисуй собаку, она не сразу знает, что собаку мы рисуем так, начинаем с головы и так далее.
Нет. Она начинает просто с изображения, на котором ничего кроме шума и дополняет его деталями, рисует формы так, чтобы результат получился правдоподобным.
То есть, она не рисует, не создает что-то конкретное, а просто генерирует что-то правдоподобное, похожее на твое описание.
Как она это делает?
Модель обучается на пикселях, на миллионах изображений, разложенных в миллиарды пикселей и пиксельных паттернов.
Когда она видит запрос, какой-нибудь там закат в горах, она не складывает буквы, она вспоминает, как обычно выглядят пиксельные паттерны для таких сцен.
Диффузионные модели, самые распространенные, это основа основ.
Flux, Stable Diffusion, Mid Journey, это все диффузионные модели.
Они, как правило, генерируют красиво, но не точно.
Поэтому, какие у них сильные и слабые стороны?
Сильные стороны диффузии, это фотореализм, какая-то природа, текстура, материалы, освещение и так далее.
Также художественный вкус, модель видела миллионы профессиональных фото, иллюстрации, она прекрасно чувствует стиль, у нее очень хорошая насмотренность.
Как раз-таки самая крутая именно по стилю модель Mid Journey, именно диффузионная.
Ну и стилизация, то есть ты не можешь конкретные элементы переносить и так далее.
Диффузионные модели, как правило, делают это плохо, но именно стилистику воспроизводят они отлично.
Ну и где работают плохо диффузионные модели, это все то, где нужна точность.
То есть какой-то текст на изображениях, это уже конкретные символы, их нужно отрисовать и не просто правдоподобно воспроизвести, как делают диффузионные модели.
Также это сложные инструкции, когда ты там описываешь, тут один человек в такой одежде, здесь у меня, я не знаю, пальма с кокосами, под ними такой-то дорожный знак и так далее.
Это все огромное количество конкретных задач и условий.
А она, опять же, воспроизводит какую-то правдоподобную картинку.
Она лучше будет генерировать то, что уже видела, то, что уже могло быть.
Если ты просишь фотореалистичное изображение с нереалистичной сценой, набором различных объектов и прочего, то для нее это будет затруднительно.
Ну и удержание контекста.
Каждая новая генерация, это задача с нуля.
Ты не можешь сказать диффузионной модели, здорово, теперь мне тут что-нибудь дорисуй.
Нет, она просто заново все перегенерирует, многое изменится и, конечно, нам это не подходит.
И, конечно, зачастую это бесит, это не подходит, но мы в рамках этого модуля будем разбираться, как редактировать точечный результат.
Вторая архитектура, это гибридные авторегрессивные модели.
Это новые модели, которые появились в индустрии относительно недавно и закрыли слабые стороны диффузионных.
Какой тут принцип?
Внутри две части.
Первый это языковая модель, второй это визуальный движок.
Языковая модель понимает, что ты пишешь, что ты имеешь в виду и дает инструкции визуальному движку.
Уже управляет им, чтобы он отрисовывал какие-то конкретные объекты.
Называется это авторегрессивные, потому что модель генерирует поэтапно, но при этом удерживая контекст.
Сначала композиция, потом детали, потом текст, потом финал.
На каждом этапе она знает, что было раньше.
Самые такие яркие, громкие примеры это Nano Banana Pro либо 2 и GPT Image.
Какие у нас сильные и слабые стороны у гибридных моделей?
Сильные стороны.
Самое главное здесь точность.
То есть, например, текст на изображениях она прекрасно воспроизводит.
GPT Image последний.
Вообще практически безошибочно это делает на любом языке мира.
Также это точное исследование промту.
Сколько бы ты ни описал условий, там они будут изложены.
Но имей в виду, что, как правило, когда ты пишешь огромное количество условий в промте,
то приоритет отдается первым, а последние могут вообще забыться.
Ну и многошаговое редактирование.
То есть, модель понимает, когда ты ему говоришь,
окей, здорово, теперь на это фото что-нибудь добавь.
Она возьмет его, добавит только туда и, как правило, ничего не изменит.
Но и тут бывают погрешности.
И где гибридные модели проигрывают?
Первое, это разрешение.
У некоторых гибридов оно скромнее, чем у топовых диффузионных моделей.
Также художественный вкус так себе, прям очень посредственно.
Эти модели больше про точность.
Нужно максимально подробно описывать тот стиль, который ты хочешь воспроизвести,
если хочешь, чтобы изображение было сочным.
И последний минус, это скорость.
Эти модели думают, разбивают генерацию на этапы,
соответственно, на это нужно больше времени.
И следующее важное разделение, вообще, в принципе, глобальное разделение моделей,
это открытый и проприетарный.
Это уже не про архитектуру, а просто про доступ к этим моделям.
Открытые модели, ну, думаю, понятно, их можно скачать, запустить, да обучить.
Можно использовать их локально.
Как правило, они дешевые в использовании в каких-то сторонних сервисах,
в агрегаторах, как вот, например, в крем, но они, как правило, слабее.
То есть, качество в них, в основном, достигается мощностью машины,
на которой они работают.
Если ты используешь эти модели локально,
то тебе нужно качать их вариации, их сборки, там, на 40, 50 и более гигабайт,
и быть готовым к тому, что они прям очень жестко будут мучить твой компьютер,
если ты хочешь использовать их локально.
Они могут быть полезными, когда ты работаешь, например, с какой-то конфиденциальной информацией,
когда тебе нужно генерировать целые паки ассетов,
делать это часто, постоянно, ну и, в общем, дорого будет выходить,
делать это в каком-то стороннем сервисе.
Это если речь идет о локальной генерации.
Если мы используем в каких-то агрегаторах эти модели,
то там они отличные помощники, внести небольшие правки,
создать какое-то там проходное быстрое изображение,
сделать несколько итераций визуала и так далее,
потому что они, как правило, дешевые и работают быстро.
Ну и лидеры рынка, это, как правило, проприетарные модели.
Доступ к ним есть только через интерфейс конкретно их создателей,
либо в других платформах.
Например, Midjourney, Nano Banana, GPT Image.
Здесь, если Nano Banana и GPT модели зачастую доступны во всех агрегаторах,
то Midjourney – это вот единственная модель,
которая стоит особняком и никому никак не позволяет им пользоваться,
кроме своего дискорда и своего отдельного сайта.
По визуалу это лидер рынка, и он строго держит в тайне,
не выдавая, как оно работает.
Удобно, что, как правило, эти модели сразу в нормальном интерфейсе,
с ними легко работать, не нужна никакая настройка.
Минусы в том, что полного контроля нет,
мы не видим, как оно там внутри работает,
но не сказал бы, что нам это сильно нужно.
И давайте еще закрепим способы доступа к моделям.
У нас есть облачный SaaS,
то есть готовый какой-то интерфейс,
с которым мы взаимодействуем.
ChatGPT, Midjourney, Nano Banana –
такой способ взаимодействия поддерживают.
Также API через провайдеров –
это когда мы хотим по API генерировать визуал.
Это, как правило, используется для разработчиков.
Например, нужно это где-то в каком-то приложении.
Вот, предположим, Сбербанк придумал,
что они хотят продвигать своего маскота,
и сейчас проходит активность,
узнай, какой у тебя бы был Сбер-код.
И он как-нибудь там, этот код генерируется,
кастомизируется под твои траты,
под их там объем, чем ты интересуешься и так далее.
У тебя твой уникальный Сбер-код.
В таком случае Сбер,
если бы хотел прибегнуть именно к внешним сторонним сервисам,
разработчики заложили бы туда API,
по которому приложение делало бы запрос
на сервера провайдеров,
тех, кто там эти модели создал.
Там бы генерировалось это изображение,
возвращалось обратно в приложение
и отображалось у человека.
Ну, в общем, эта штука сугубо для разработчиков нам это не нужно.
Также для открытых моделей есть доступ локально на своем устройстве,
но, опять же, устройство нужно мощное,
и чтобы получился хороший результат и быстро,
нужно ставить огромные модели
и ресурсы своей машины выделять по максимуму.
То есть, если хочешь реально что-то крутое,
то, скорее всего, параллельно на этом компьютере работать не сможешь.
Ну и гибридные агрегаторы,
их представитель Крия,
в которой мы будем работать весь этот модуль,
там у нас, как правило, есть все.
Итак, давай сведем все в карту решений.
Если у нас задача фотореализм,
иллюстрации, художественный, визуал,
нам нужна диффузионная модель.
Это Flux 2 Pro, либо MidJourney.
Flux 2 Pro у нас есть в Крие,
а MidJourney доступен только на сайте MidJourney и в их Дискорде.
Если у нас текст на изображениях,
инфографика, многоязычные баннеры,
нам нужна точность.
Это гибридные модели.
Nano Banana, GPT.
Используем либо их собственные чатики, либо Крию.
Если у нас многошаговое редактирование,
удержание персонажа,
то есть мы сгенерировали первую итерацию,
сказали, что нужно добавить и так далее,
мы используем, опять же, те же самые гибридные модели.
Но тут есть нюанс.
Если мы хотим что-то уникальное,
какого-то крутого персонажа,
мы комбинируем диффузию и гибрид.
То есть идем сначала в MidJourney,
говорим, сделай крутого персонажа.
Он делает сразу крутой визуал,
который хотелось бы поправить.
С этим уже мы идем в гибридные модели
и доводим до идеала.
Далее, если у нас кастомный стейлпак под бренд,
плюс дообучение на своих ассетах,
то есть выведение какой-то стилистики бренда,
то это тоже диффузия плюс гибрид.
И зачастую для этого еще используют локальные модели.
Но необходимости в этом никакой нет.
Мы можем делать это все через ноды
в генераторах таких, как Cria и Vivi.
Ну и в целом, повседневная работа,
проверка идей, эксперименты,
какие-нибудь превью для видео,
в моем случае,
это универсальная модель.
Ну и повседневная работа,
проверка идей, эксперименты,
какие-то быстрые, сочные визуалы.
Просто берем Cria,
она универсальна,
что угодно ты там найдешь.
На этом все, урок теоретический,
поэтому домашнего задания у нас не будет.
В следующем уроке мы рассматриваем
базовые подходы генерации.
До встречи в следующем уроке.